لا تغير ينتظر في سياسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده بخصوص استمرار
الغارات على ما تسميه اسرائيل التموضع
الايراني في سوريا او مواجهه المشروع
النووي
الايرانيات سد دوائر امنيه واستراتيجيه
اسرائيليه من ان يقود وجود متطرفين في
الحكومه الى اشعال مواجهه مع الفلسطينيين
ما قد يؤثر على العلاقه مع الاداره
الامريكيه الديمقراطيه حتى في التعاون على
مواجهه ايران
لعمليه التي تحدثنا عنها والتي نحذر منها
عمليه تهديد الدعم الامريكي الاوتوماتيكي
لاسرائيل على المدى الطويل واحتمال ميسي
بالعلاقات الخاصه مع الامريكيين وفي
الخلفيه انتقادات الديمقراطيين لنتنياهو
ورغم ان اسرائيل اجرد مناورات فرديه واخرى
مشتركه مع الامريكيين ودول اخرى حاكه
استهداف المنشات النوويه الايرانيه الى ان
القدره العسكريه علشان هجوم اسرائيليا
منفرد لم تكتمل بعد معضله اسرائيل ان
استراتيجيتها باتت تعليقه منعت الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران لكن بدون وجود خطه دوليه
او حتى اسرائيليه جاهزه بينما تهرب ودود
طهران نحو القنبله النوويه تخصيدا
لليورانيوم
بين الاداره الامريكيه وهمم اسرائيل في
نظرها الى الملف الايراني والى طريقه
التعامل مع هذا التهديد علاقه نتنياه
الفاتره باداره بيد وتشكيكه فيها بتاكيده
مؤخرا فقط بانه لن يشاركها امر الضربه لا
خشيه من تسريب الامر لمنعها قد يترك
اسرائيل وحدها في المواجهه الى حد كبير ثم
ادراك استراتيجيه في اسرائيل بان استهداف
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه يحتاج دعمنه
وتسليح النوعيه الامريكيه لتنفيذه بنجاح
والا فان التلويحه بالضرب يصبح تلويحا
بمسدس فارغ من الطلقه زياد حلبي العربيه
القدس الغربيه